Please welcome Zachariah Porter!
(clapping)
Oh my god, I am so excited to meet you.
A dream come true.
I mean, you are really freaking people out.
They love your videos.
I know, and I,
I can't believe it it's been the best year of my life.
Seriously. I'm so honored to do it.
What, like,
Even made you come up with this idea?
Oh, it's so funny.
So I am a snacker through and through,
and I love a midnight snack the most.
So it was just like one night I opened the fridge.
I did that, like classic, like refrigerator open.
And I was like, what can I make?
And I saw, I had these Crescent rolls and I was like,
you know what,
let's see what I can kind of pack these with
and just try a bunch out.
And then we brought the best ones for you today that I love.
But yeah, just to find like that.
You know, if it's okay.
I wanted to invite someone to this party.
Oh, I love guests.
You do?
Let's do it
Okay. Well,
she's one of my favorite people
and we're lucky enough that
she's going to join us.
Please welcome back to the show.
The beautiful and talented Vanessa Hudgens.
(clapping)
I just want to squeeze you so badly.
I want to squeeze him so badly.
The cuteness aggression is so real.
Like when somebody has fleas, but in a good way.
Yeah, yeah exactly.
I'm so happy to see you,
I'm so happy to see you.
And Zach, we are hoping that you can show us
how to make your mystery puffs.
Yes.
And that's the beauty of this.
It's so simple that we could
literally have like six conversations going on at once
and still get through it all.
I don't think I've ever used an air fryer before.
Oh, really?
Yeah. I'm like, how does it work?
Yeah. This is a, this is a gorgeous Air-Fryer.
I'm very excited to say that I actually made this myself.
I did. I designed it
It's beautiful.
That's what it's called. Beautiful.
I'm just- I'm psychic.
Zach, what are we putting in the puffs?
So we have a cookie puff, a fruit puff,
and then we have a tomato and mozzarella puff.
Interesting.
Yeah, are you ready to get going?
Yes, I am.
Let's make things.
Let's do it. Okay.
So the first one we have here
is a Milano cookie.
So what you're to do,
just put it on the triangle and just roll the crescent.
So yeah, let's put it right in the air fire too.
We won't put it on yet, but we'll just get it set up.
Yeah. Right in there.
And then after that,
we're going to move on to the cantaloupe.
I'm not very comfortable in a kitchen. Can you tell?
By the way,
Thank you, Vanessa.
Welcome to my world.
This is the Lucille Ball kitchen.
You're going to fit right in.
I love it.
This one we're going to do now
is the cantaloupe crescent roll
and really quickly did you, I don't know.
(stuttering)
You probably both, do you know how to, I don't know.
Do you know how to cut a cantaloupe?
No.
Do you?
I mean, here's what I would do with it.
I would just cut it down the middle.
Not- you're you're honestly on the right track,
right there.
I'm going to be honest with you.
I am?
That is not what I was expecting.
Well, I think too, I think since, well,
some of us aren't comfortable in the kitchen.
No, some of us have this thing I like to call,
I don't know. We have like melon anxiety,
because we're just like so scared to like,
buy a full melon ever.
And I've realized like,
this is as simply as just cutting off the ends,
slicing it down the middle and there it is.
And this one is going to be the most intensive here
and it's seriously on, not even.
So grab your olive oil,
a little drizzle.
Don't be scared.
And then from there you just gonna grab your seasoning
and just do a little pinch of it,
right over everything.
What kind of seasoning is this?
Oh, good question.
So we're doing garlic powder,
crushed red pepper,
salt and oregano.
Oh. And then from here, it's really simple.
So we're gonna grab our little knives
and you guys can do it the way that you want to.
We're just gonna basically kind of line this top region
right here.
A tip I learned, also,
if you're having a hard time
and you're cutting a tiny little thing
and it's, like, not really going through
and you have a dull knife,
do a little pokey
and then your knife will go nicely right into it.
And it will open.
Ooh.
I have a lot of dull knives.
Me too
Me too.
Really?
I feel like with how you smash that into the board,
you and sharp knives are like, best friends.
I, I need to get a knife sharpener.
Roll it.
Wow.
That knife was sharp. That was sharp right there.
Got it. Okay.
There we go.
I can't-
Place it right in there. So from here,
what you would do is you were going to close this.
You're going to put it in at 300 degrees for five minutes.
Take your tongs.
Kind of toss them a little bit so they don't stick.
So one of the things that I wanted to do with this design
was like a sleeker technological design.
We're only moving forward into the future.
So here it's all a touch screen.
So I'm going to touch it.
I'm going to push air fry.
Chic.
Zachariah?
300 for this one.
(audience laughing and clapping)
Time?
How long, Zachariah?
Five minutes on this first round.
350, you said?
300.
Oh that's okay.
And then air fry.
Hit that.
Vanessa is killing it over here.
I did it!
I'm doing well in the kitchen.
All right.
Now we're going to taste them because
TV magic says we have beautiful ones right here.
You can all take ours and put it over here.
Cause that's sort of the funnest part.
Best part.
Should we start with the Milanos?
Yeah, absolutely.
Oh.
You don't like it?
I love it.
It's like a chocolate croissant.
Well what do you think about this one?
I want to rank them. I think it's more fun that way.
If we can rank them one out of ten.
What I like about this?
Is that- a one out of ten?
Yeah. Well, just be honest.
I think it's like, it was good.
It's not like giving a hundred percent.
I'm going to give it a six.
Yeah. That's fair.
Can I try? I got excited.
I tried the cantaloupe.
We're going for it. We're moving forward.
Let's do it
I think I know where you're headed with this one.
Wait, you're not loving. Are you living?
I'm not loving it as much.
Hold on,
I hate it.
(clapping)
I'm going to defend this real quick. Okay.
Go for it. Go for it.
This is TV magic. If it was fresh out that air fryer.
Let me tell you transported to the south of France.
That is effervescent. It's buttery.
It's great
Heat makes a big difference and those are not hot, hot.
Thank you. Okay.
So the last one we'll cut it in half. This one's chunky.
I like that. Ooh.
I can get down with this.
It tastes how I wanted it to taste.
And we saved it for last for an obvious reason.
Yeah, no,
this is a classic.
I need, like, a glass of wine.
Sit down with this,
Don't play with me.
Maybe a book.
Okay. This one, I'm going in for the second bite.
Oh good.
You know, I love this one.
So this one, I would rate it a 10.
Yeah. Ten.
And by the way, today,
everyone in our audience are going to go home
with a beautiful air fryer.
(screaming applause)
Including you guys.
They come in four colors, as you saw,
I'm super proud of these
and they're exclusive
and available at Walmart,
as is the whole line at walmart.com.
But you are going home with them today.
Thank you.
Zachariah, this is the beginning of a beautiful friendship.
As they say in Casa Blanca.
Thank you, oh my god,
It was so nice meeting you.